so cop 28 just finished in Dubai and was
this a victory well let me put it like
this imagine that you own a house and
that house is on fire and you know why
it's on fire you watched your neighbor
throw a Molotov cocktail through your
window and for the past 20 minutes he's
actually just been throwing more and
more petrols Through the Windows of your
house making it burn more and more and
you called the fire brigade of course
but after you did that he then got in
his car drove it down the street and
just parked in the middle of the the
road so that the firr can't get to you
but about a minute ago something strange
happened while he continues to throw
petrol into your house with one hand he
turns to you and says yeah it's kind of
my fault isn't it and then in his other
hand he gets a superer and he just
starts languidly firing a jet of water
towards your
house is that a win look I came into cop
28 with very low expectations as I think
did most climate commentators and you
can see why it was being hosted in a
Petro State the president of cop 28 was
the head of the state oil company and
investigative journalists found out that
that company was planning to use cop 28
to sign more oil deals so I came into
this with low expectations and the final
text of cot 28 is better than I and I
think also most people expected but I
share my opinion with James Dyke who's a
researcher at the University of exor's
Global Systems Institute who said that
this deal has been hailed as a landmark
is more a measure of previous failures
than any step change when it comes to
the increasingly urgent need to rapidly
stop burning coal oil and gas sure this
is better than what we've been dealing
with before but that doesn't
automatically make this a good final Tex
that's not to say that there were no
positives that came out of cop 28 I was
very pleasantly surprised to see that
for the first time for 3ars of
agricultural emissions they are going to
be included in Count's nationally
determined contributions or ndc's which
is like the carbon budget for each
country we also saw a similar agreement
for emissions from cooling which is
another significant source of missions
from air conditioning and the like there
was also the early win at the very start
of the conference on the loss and damage
fund we now have that kind of more
formally set up even if the amount of
money that's been pledged so far has
been pretty woeful and the pledge for
many countries to Triple their
deployment of Renewables and double
Energy Efficiency which is something the
Ia were calling for before cop 28 but
ultimately cop 28 will be judged on its
final text and more specifically than
that part one Article 28 this is the
meat of what cop agreed and in
particular everyone's talking about
subsection d calling on parties to
transition away from fossil fuels and
energy systems in a just orderly and
Equitable manner accelerating action in
this critical decade so as to achieve
Net Zero by 2050 in keeping with the
science which I like to imagine was
included purely out of spite by the cop
28 chairman after those comments he made
leaked so this is notable because it is
the first time that a cop final text has
explicitly called out fossil fuels as
the cause of the problem and calling for
people to transition away from them and
that is a historic first but again
that's only a historic first because we
were so woeful at this in the past and
many headlines have been made about the
fact that I believe two days before the
final text was agreed it originally
included the phrase phase out of fossil
fuels and this was removed allegedly at
the insistence of Saudi Arabia though it
should be noted that other countries
also objected to the language in
particular countries whose economies
depend on fossil fuel extraction and
were not unjustifiably worried about the
energy transition that was coming this
is where I put my effective Global
agreement on climate Finance if I had
one and so we were left with this final
text that calls upon countries to
transition away from fossil fuels which
is quite fluffy it's important to note
that United Nations language is quite
specific so calls upon is not the
weakest language that we could have got
we could have got requests but equally
it's not as strong as urges countries or
demands countries which was never going
to happen so this final statement isn't
as weak as it could be but equally it is
nowhere near as strong as scientists and
activists were demanding this isn't in
line with what science is telling us we
need to be doing in order to limit
warming to less than 2 or 1.5° and while
subsection D has got a lot of attention
I'd also like to draw your attention to
subsection B which calls on parties to
accelerate efforts towards the phase
down of unabated coal power and the key
word here is unabated because in this
context that's code for carbon capture
and storage or CCS CCS refers to
capturing the carbon that's emitted from
burning a fuel like say coal at the
point where you burn the coal and then
burying it and it's a technique that
sounds eminently sensible right and it's
certainly what countries that burn a lot
of coal want to do going forwards and
it's what the companies that produce the
coal are saying we should be doing going
forwards but I I cannot be more explicit
about this it's not a solution multiple
Studies have been done including by the
ipcc on whether we can keep burning
fossil fuels but just do ccs to capture
those emissions the answer is a
resounding no it is not a practical
solution it's it's just not going to
happen so the use of the word unabated
in this text which I believe originated
in cop 26 in Glasgow refers to a
solution that isn't a solution and this
is the kind of language that we'll
probably see going forwards in future
cops when we refer to oil and gas as
well so whilst it is good that coal has
been singled out because it is the
dirtiest most polluting of the fossil
fuels it's still being singled out with
this caveat of unabated coal use which I
I can't I just simply cannot stress
enough that c s is not the solution to
this and what worries me is that going
forwards when we do have cops that will
explicitly call for the phase out of
fossil fuels in general I believe that
it's going to use this language again
and it's going to talk about unabated
use of fossil fuels the phase down of
unabated fossil fuels and this CCS idea
is going to be a crutch going
forwards don't fall for it editing Simon
here I've realized that another
important perspective to put in this
video is was cop 28 a success from the
point of view of fossil fuel companies
and I think cop 28 was the ideal outcome
for these companies like if you think
about it they have positioned themselves
the UAE a Petro state was able to chair
a conference that said we need to
transition away from fossil fuels and
they can point to the fact this was
historic and they've really taking the
climate crisis seriously but if you
actually dig into what the text says it
talks about the unabated use of fossil
fuels which means that Petro States
fossil fuel producing companies
aren't going to be affected it doesn't
change their business model because they
can continue to extract and sell and in
fact expand their operations of
extraction and selling to other
countries of oil and gas and coal but
the onus is put on the people who are
using those fuels to use ccs to capture
the emissions doesn't affect those P
States doesn't affect the companies at
all and in fact this gives them some
really powerful messaging that they can
put out in years to come that say that
says we were there at the most
historically important moment in the
fight against climate change and we
agree we need to do something about this
we need to stop the unabated use of
fossil fuels it is a colossal
greenwashing win for these companies and
I I I just need you to come away from
this video knowing that when they say we
are taking this really
seriously I don't think they are
anyway I think a reasonable assessment
of cop 28 was this was an iterative
improvement yes a historic first the
first time we've talked about
transitioning away from fossil fuels but
that is the most minuscule of steps
forward and if this was a problem that
wasn't so time specific if it wasn't so
time critical that we actually
implemented a solution now then I think
I'd be happy to chalk this up as a win
and this is just the nature of
international negotiations but this is a
Time critical problem and every year
that we delay taking meaningful action
as I talked about in my previous video
millions of lives are on the line over
on threads where incidentally you can
follow me if you like climate Professor
Katherine heho pointed out that the
promises made at cop 28 get us to 30% of
the emissions reductions necessary to
limit warming to 1 and 1/ 12° c and
every year that we delay meaningful
action the drop off of emissions
necessary to limit warming to 1 and A2
de gets steeper and steeper and frankly
more unrealistic so would you Class A
small incremental win at a critical time
like this as a victory your house is
still on fire and sure maybe the stream
from the super sooka will partially save
part of your garage but the person
responsible for causing the fire is
still blocking meaningful action and
stopping the fire brigade from arriving
with their hoses I should probably point
out by the way at this point that I
believe limiting warming to 1 and A2 de
C is not going to happen that is a
practical impossibility at this point
the challenge in my opinion is whether
we can limit it to less than two degrees
of warming and I genuinely believe that
we can I mean you can watch the video I
made a couple of weeks ago on that
subject I believe that that is practical
and I believe it is possible but I don't
believe that cop 28 got us to where we
need to be to accomplish that goal
really cop 28 just reflected what
countries around the world were already
doing they were already rolling out more
Renewables they were already
transitioning away from fossil fuels but
is that what we want comp to be do we
want cop to be the place where people
just turn up and put their bill stickers
up and say this is what we've been doing
and then the International Community
Loosely agrees on a text that says yeah
this is roughly what we're all doing is
that the point or is the point of cop to
get more ambitious and to improve
cooperation and allow for more ambitious
more meaningful action the next two cops
are in aaban and then Brazil and maybe
in two years time just maybe we'll see a
final text that actually has some bite
to it that has some meaningful action on
the phase out of fossil fuels not just
unabated fossil fuels but fossil fuels
because in the next 2 years is I can
guarantee you that the impacts of
climate change are only going to get
more and more obvious by the time we get
to Brazil maybe we'll have enough
ambition in the room to really make a
difference the question is by
then will it be a bit too late I don't
have a sponsor for this video because I
decided to make it super last minute
originally this was just going to be
part of next week's video which is a
review of everything that happened in
climate news in 2023 so if you're not
subscribed hit the subscribe button and
make sure you don't miss that one that
means this video was entirely supported
by my lovely patrons thank you to
everybody who supports me over on
patreon.com Ox Fizz the names of people
you're seeing on the screen right now
are my executive producer patrons all
patrons get access to videos before they
go out on YouTube you also get access to
exclusive behind the scenes content so I
do a monthly Vlog like my PhD Vlogs used
to be and if you're a producer or
executive producer you get to vote on a
video topic once a month going forwards
the past couple of months have been a
bit disruptive because of you know baby
thank you for watching the video I hope
that it was informative maybe it helped
you form an opinion yourself on cop 28
let me know your thoughts down in the
comments and if you enjoyed the video
please do pop it a like there's some
recommended viewing on the screen right
now and that just leaves me to say thank
you for watching I'll see you in the
next one